cooper car season three episode two
excited to cover this guys if you
haven't done so already subscribe
click that notification bell so you can
get notified when our next cobra kai
reaction
is up while you're at it hit that like
button or you know
smash
no mercy break its back and put it in a
cone and as per usual this is youtube so
i can only do reaction highlights for
you guys here full length ratchet and
watch alongs where you sync with the
time code
or all over at our patreon page and i
want to thank everyone who has become a
patron jack thus far
over there we cover so many shows we're
at the same tier
you get the option for reaction
highlights and watch along included
shows like this one and that one
and that one and that one is it going
too fast to the point where you can't
read the title you're looking at her
face
which one is it look over there to find
out anywho let's do this
we're looking at creases backstory oh
probably
i wouldn't have put a 65.
that's got to be creased they're the
opponent you don't show them mercy
i'm going to start karate school what
are you looking at
freak is a freak if you love him so much
start a service
i love that line
we can use you out there in vietnam man
very inspiring
we'll uh we'll sure think about it show
them respect
cut to vietnam or is that crease uh oh
i love that flipparoo oh my god it
probably is
yeah yeah the whole time you thought you
were
he was creased
oh my god am i gonna start feeling sorry
for crease now
you lost soldiers and you lost the bat
jesus
they're all white belts man totally
forgot about the belts
we will strike back and we will strike
off with no mercy
oh it's gonna be a fun episode
no no no don't what is it what do you
need i need a kick
touchy subject
people gonna fight back with yoga this
is what rehab's like
this is one of the best facilities in
the country oh rehab looks
great you all should go
oh rehab welcome to malibu canyon
recovery
malibu you're doing a very brave thing
oh golly i'm no quitter
oh no
[Music]
i almost didn't recognize her at first
yeah i know
they did a good like transformation i
don't need some rehab vacation
that's because your idea of vacation is
going to some
monster truck monster jam you loved
every minute of i was faking
you're going to put her back on the
bottle guys whenever robbie would get in
trouble those dimwits weren't far behind
what do it one looks like chris brown
the other one looks vaguely
oh those guys i know where they are
they're at my house so before you're
dismissed
i have a little treat for you punch him
in the face
what are you gonna do oh what's his name
i don't know what are you going to do
what do you think
don't do it
no god no
no he's so cute guys oh
no you know it's almost lunch time can i
feed him
no you can eat him but you can feed him
what does he like to eat he likes to eat
clams oh
no oh i officially i have no sympathy
for him
no sympathy for chris no he's also a
biology teacher
this is a lab now
oh that poor mouse i can't
feed you to the snake it's okay to
object
i do not like this who else object
hawk don't you're off the team
the augie doe just got a whole bunch
more
oh no
[Music]
oh i hate him he used to be an enjoyable
bad guy
the true cobra feels no sympathy for its
meals
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
that's definitely you
nice is back
nope my heart will never go sensitive to
you
i hate you show will not win
hello there if i handsome
do my job then you can't live here why
do all these east coast people live in
california i don't know if i had some
mud in an inflatable pool i could have
sold tickets
not boy you too fought over with a sat
front and sounded ugh
what would your probation officer say oh
i think on what i said maybe i'll see
you tonight
oh
my god
karate that's not gonna help the leak
does it look like i'm scared of you you
should be i don't think so man
look at your face looks like you already
got your ass beat
[Music]
[Laughter]
kevin james
i can do this all day hey
all right now here's a board break it
how about this no
no i'm gonna buy your mom for a second
okay he cannot do karate let me put it
on a big white board for you
no corrode miguel will get back on his
feet don't lose hope audience who's
already seen the whole series
well we know he'll get back on his feet
wiggle your
big toe oh
corn nuts johnny lawrence is with me oh
hi johnny oh hey amanda all right
just talk normal all right
scumbags at the prison gave it up easy
couple of [ __ ]
yeah they wouldn't talk so we had a
snack we did what i'm not going back to
the dojo
trying to get my ged taking care of my
little brother and my mom
and i have to pay rent on time this
month oh chris can kick that guy's ass
there you go she's sick mine was too
you lived in a place even less charming
than this if you can believe it
right on time
so did she get better no
i killed her fed her to a snake it was a
different kind of sickness
[ __ ] sick she had too much mercy
what if you do is run me
those other students they weren't born
fighters
like you you got a scholarship you need
every hour i can get it
yes girls
chris go take care of it go take care of
it crease
go she gave the look turn around yeah
she's been looking at them
increase the whole time be bad chris
beat up this other guy
don't ever let me catch you making eyes
like that again
oh he's the one who wanted to get
involved now he's involved
damn it jesus
[Music]
yeah yeah oh
i like young crease and see i
transitioned instead of
are they perfect that's something i
can't believe you eat that cup
oh what you do good for uh gas station
food yeah i am
miguel amanda says he woke up oh please
tell johnny
good news
[Music]
or at least a freeze frame high five the
fan
oh snap go on tango with cash
oh jesus
oh damn we going to get a fight
oh all right we can work this out
get too wet let's get to it we're not
whoa oh
wow dude
they they they're fighting together
it just died on me
literally team
damn
get in there johnny oh yeah
they ready they read each other where is
he what kid
oh come on
oh that's too much where is he no i
swear stop it all right
guys no come on you just started
fighting together guys no
no
i can't believe you actually taught kids
what could happen to robbie i'm willing
to admit when i fail
oh maybe you just have a little too much
of you in you
oh
damn no
no i got somewhere
no no no it's just me johnny's
okay okay slow down all right i'm on my
way
she had the baby
here we go oh yeah here it comes she can
do something else to get in my good
graces right
yes
i'm sorry
[Music]
oh
i was i wanted him to do it get rid of
that neck brace thing that's good
notice i hit yours from nerds
doctor told my mom i might not walk
again i don't know how strong you are
sensei
did you talk me show mercy
to me know oh
you don't know i trusted you oh
oh no don't turn your back no oh no
no look at me
oh no damn it
[Music]
poor mcgill it's gonna be okay robbie
we'll figure this out wow
okay right there you little [ __ ] come
here
damn it
he looks unrecognizable with that hair
hey it's like
three years younger i'm so sorry no but
you were right it was mistake trying to
help me because i can't change we all
make mistakes
[Music]
our mistakes aren't who we are this next
part is gonna be really really hard
okay but this is the best way forward oh
no
i spoke to a lawyer and he explained
that oh no it's happening i knew it oh
no
no no
he has to he has to be talking someone
want to leave
yeah damn one united
purpose yep there it goes there's the
door
that issue i was having got worked out
now you can start spending all your rent
money here on class
[Music]
i am that's what i'm talking about
that's what i'm talking about yeah i
love when cobra kai gets all serious
i love when it gets heavy on the drama
man
that was good that was some good writing
right there really had you going because
it starts off as a sense of unity and
then everything falls apart and the only
thing that's coming together is cobra
kai
yes his team of unstoppable strong heads
because yeah you start off with johnny
and danny working together to really
really get they really have you going
you're like this might be it this might
be the turning point for them
this is the time when they're going to
start bonding and working together on
things and
it makes me wonder like i don't get too
bogged down predictions
it does make me wonder how robbie going
to jail
will turn out in johnny's eyes because i
don't think johnny would be on board for
such an
outcome but it seemed like the right
step it was the right good call i mean
that's always the
odds that they're at it's like danny
tries to take more of the
morally good path a lot of the time the
right thing
and then also kind of capping it off
with creases
monologue which i thought was really
interesting at the end
of the perception that we we assign
what's good
we assign what's bad there really is no
such thing but what we assign it to
and that there's only strong and weak
that tends to be the dichotomy between
johnny and danny is how their approaches
constantly are at odds with each other
and how they always think they're in the
right
and they always think the other person's
in the wrong so it's kind of funny to
have
crease the villain of this series have
this
monologue to his class sort of be the
center point of what creates this divide
between our two protagonists
you know on the idea that everybody
thinks that they're the hero and that's
really well i think exemplified like
across
this whole episode because like
everybody seems like they've
been wronged in some way and then you
get to see
perspectives on characters that you
wouldn't have uh you know identified as
much
not that they may increase like a
lovable guy but getting some backstory
into him i thought was a really
interesting
touch and then having it come around
with tori and the whole
landlord thing like it's interesting i i
as of season two you know kind of hate
you know i
love to hate but hate crease and in this
season i'm sitting here wondering
are they gonna try and like really
humanize him
or are they gonna just bring him down to
a level of understanding before we
you know vanquish him in one way or
another for the season
yeah i mean after the whole thing we're
torturing the mouse
i mean yes i know some people feed their
snakes
with animals like that like mice
i think i'm getting the animal thing
right yeah right yeah
it's natural but there was also a lot of
taunting along the way and there was
this
it was not just the matter it was the
manner of how he did the matter yeah
that was the problematic part for me
mainly
yeah and he clearly delights in watching
what happens
and going about it so after that no
there's no chance in hell you could ever
win me on chris's side
that's very on the karate kid movie
three karate kid movies the season of
the cobra guy
and this is the turning point for me yep
there's nothing you could ever do i
don't care how much flashbacks you show
me into the sad
sad life he had and how unfortunate he
was
nah i mean i'll understand him more but
i don't think he could ever win me on
his side after that
yeah i mean like that's probably about
the best you can hope for is just being
like
oh how how sad i understand how you
wound up
this way yeah but it seems like he's
very much set in his
waist to the point where he's not gonna
have like a huge character change i
wouldn't expect anyway
because he's usually the guy who's fun
to not like and this
this pushed it into an area of oh now i
just don't like you
yeah you're like a colorful villain up
into a point and then when he starts
really revealing the more sadistic
aspects
and the you know like unc like unconcern
for life in in a certain degree yeah and
they've really pushed this in a
in a territory where now i really don't
know where it's going and i love how you
can do that from first episode to second
episode
this first episode of like all right
miguel's gonna wake up he's looking for
johnny and then robbie will reunite with
danny and
it's like okay but they're probably both
gonna be on you know some good paths and
then you get to this point
and it's like they have both have a
fallout you know and i love that
emotional beat because that is a
that is a necessary conversation to have
miguel thought he was doing the right
thing
he showed mercy it was a big change in
his character from what we saw in season
two and now that's landed him
possibly he's not going to be but you
know and the moment i'll believe it
but he's not going to be i would love it
if i'm wrong
i wouldn't i wouldn't love it but i'd be
surprised it would be a great drama
it would be really surprising if like
whoa he really doesn't ever walk again
yeah yeah well i feel like that was the
main thrust of what i really enjoyed
about this episode something you touched
on earlier is like yeah you have all
these hopeful moments of like oh
miguel's waking up and johnny and danny
maybe there's gonna be some harmony and
maybe we're going to mobilize against
crees and then all of it
falls apart and i think that like to
build the stakes of your season this was
really smart because the first episode
felt like setting the plates
and making sure we have like a good read
on where everyone's at and then this one
really feels like it set up
a lot of the tension in the stakes yes
this season
yeah because the show has you going on
the hopefulness
my mind once you do the scene with
miguel and johnny
my mind immediately went okay well if
that's the fallout with them
then that must mean robbie and danny are
gonna end up okay
because they wouldn't do that
back-to-back they wouldn't do a double
beat right and it wasn't a
double beat in the same way because one
is going to
jail yes and the other one uh chooses to
like says get away from me which is
heartbreaking because one of the main
like to me the biggest heart of this
series is the relationship between
johnny and miguel
and to have that be a direct fallout i
don't know what that would do to johnny
like what that would make him become and
then of course
danny and robbie there's so many e's
here johnny danny robbie miguel
all we need is crazy and then we'll be
good
[Laughter]
i'm also looking forward to seeing what
happens with the amanda character
because i don't want her to she's always
close to bordering on the line
of nagging wife in television series
she's always close to there she never
has
crossed that mark for me it was even
here i'm like no you're charming
yeah you know and she's always got the
voice of reason to the point where
you're like i get it
yeah even if i'm not even if i'm still
with danny and johnny i get you but
these choices just keep seeming so bad
you know yeah one especially as of this
episode i mean they go rogue and
beat up a bunch of criminals in a chop
shop you know
and i don't know if i i'm only just
noticing this now
maybe this is the way the show has
always been but especially watching the
last episode in this episode and having
kind of ending beats
with with daniel larusso giving some
type of inspirational speech
i think it's kind of cool since we're
doing so much of themes
of sins of our fathers or fatherly sins
that become the sun sins
that's the way the quote goes right so
that's verbatim well done oh thank god
i got it wrong last time and i had to
keep kind of beating around the butt and
then this time i was like i gotta make
sure i say it right
so do with that but then also with danny
giving the speeches and
with the fact that miyagi has all the
great quotes and all the karate kid
movies of the words of wisdom and like
you know especially when you watch it
now
like rewatch karate kid i think you've
re-watched it recently too like
i raised karate kid 2 recently and i'm
like man it'll be yucky guys it makes me
want to cry all the time
i know all those nice verses
and so i don't know if it's just because
that movie is just so fresh in my mind
right now
i've noticed they have like the modern
day touch with daniel larusso like he
doesn't seem like he's become mr miyagi
but
he tends to have the words of wisdom
yeah you know you can tell who he
learned from and and it makes me wonder
if at any point during this season we'll
have you know a requisite mr miyagi
montage of sorts where daniel
goes and reflects on his life he's gonna
be alive you know look everyone from
karate kid two and three is coming back
and mr miyagi is gonna be alive that's
right and it's gonna be deep face
that's what everyone wants that's what
the fans would be happy
you won't regret it and the fight of
them working together was great too
because i gave a visual illustration
like the moment they have the one guy
and daniel goes through the head
and then johnny goes for the leg they
read each other they worked
together in that moment without having
to say
anything and then five seconds later it
falls apart
i know one what's going to happen when
johnny finds out that his kid's in jail
exactly like i brought that up nine
minutes ago john
well you know it's just that there's
opportunity to
harp in on that point i mean it's this
kind of structure about
trying to have a proper discussion what
am i doing uh
i don't know how to review anything
johnny larusso
danny lawrence let's do it great
characters they're great
this episode made me miss the eyed a
little bit that was nice i didn't expect
to uh to get a little emotional
oh and tori tori i feel sorry for
tori nah i hate her i mean
yeah we don't really get a like
emotional beat so much as like her
circumstances which are which are you
know easy to sympathize with but
i just would be curious if they let that
character unfold just let me hate the
people i'm supposed to hate all right
don't make me feel sorry for them
nuances don't
give me a difference of perspective on
the character show
you're making me feel for people i i i
went into the season going this [ __ ]
gonna burn at the stake
and now i'm like aw crap my dad was on
dialysis her mom's on now i identify
crap and now she's your favorite
character
just mathematically that was the deal he
worked out
worked out i won't come here every week
and threaten to cut your fingers off
with my cigar chomper
if you let this girl live here for free
what is the arrangement
i don't know because like that guy could
easily i don't know go call the cops or
something
that feels like that guy would have some
moves to make but i don't know maybe
because
look guys i got one prediction one
prediction i wanna end on this i wanna
just see if
it comes true miguel's gonna join me
augie's team
and miguel and hawk are gonna face off i
can see that
for sure because i mean hawk is just
left to fester
you wait and see guys you're going to be
like wow greg you are
so good at predicting shows that can
sometimes be a little predictable
but i hope i'm wrong and then at the
very end robbie's two friends
they're gonna get out of jail and come
right in the augie dough so they can get
back at jones
very good john that's my prediction all
right guys so make sure to subscribe
click that notification bell hey who do
you prefer
tori or sam
or crease last but not least
oh man you got salmon here you got tori
in here you know who they need
sarah campbell oh they need some sarah
campbell
they need some tough chicks from canada
to be in this show
sarah you and i share a passion and love
for psychological horror film she
recommended a gazillion psychological
horror films to me
and i was like uh seven
one seven maybe that's a psychological
horror film and she told me
you know cause she's not a big star wars
fan and all that so i highly doubt she
watches cobra cod cause that's the same
fan base yeah definitely but she told me
she just recently finally started up
star wars just trying to see what all
the hypes about
now sarah what i'm hoping for is that by
the time you're all caught up with star
wars
you come back saying that is way better
than gone girl
that it's way better
oh definitely yeah that's what i'm
hoping for sarah i hope that by the end
of your
star wars journey you go wow this beats
horrendous
blood is terrible this star wars
is what it's all about horrifying only
have one or the other
but sarah and all sincerity join a
karate class would you
yeah but really in all sincerity what
are you moving to america and getting
out of that hell hole that's canada it's
going great over here right now come on
we're the best we've ever
just need 11 000 more votes that's right
one of them could be yours if you get
citizenship soon enough
what's the timeline
[Music]